do you have a sense that the most um  radical change to use that term not  pejoratively but but the most drastic  change is likely to come from within  individual states that want to try  different things or do you believe that  the most radical change is likely to  come from the federal level down  i'm guessing it's going to happen from  the states um for two reasons one  because that's how it happened in canada  and and we're very culturally and  politically similar to canada  and saskatchewan got this in the the  1960s and then uh you know other  provinces around them said well that  really works well and it saves money huh  you know let's do that and it's spread  across the country and eventually the  federal government got into the act and  said okay we will backstop you guys and  and offer some standards but every every  province in canada has their own  different medicare system